people are really freaked out about the
idea of selling and so i think the first
reframe is like you're not selling
you're helping someone make a decision
that's going to help themselves the
number one predictor of good sales is
conviction and so
fundamentally you have one person who
should believe in something
another person who does not believe it
yet and trust is the thing that
transfers that conviction fundamentally
there's the two things you need you need
trust and need conviction most times
sales people don't have 100 conviction
also the idea of conviction as a binary
is false so it's not like i believe it
or i don't believe it is to what extent
do i believe that's why like in terms of
if i want to improve a sales team i can
do the drills which we do and that's
like blocking tackling but the thing
that really juices the sales team is
hearing the testimonials of the people
that they sold last week and what
they're doing today and how their lives
have changed the thing is is like you
can either trick yourself
into having the right tone or you can
train yourself and i think that it's
much easier to trick yourself into it by
just simply believing because if you
talk if you truly believe in the product
you will talk about it differently